All right, what's up guys? I'm going
over a couple common mistakes I see
people doing very frequently with
profiles. So, this is volume profile as
well as TPO.
Uh so, I'm going to address those and
kind of how you can do this properly
instead. So,
first thing I'll touch on is going back
to the idea of balance and imbalance.
So, balance is really the only thing
that we can measure with a profile.
Right? So, if the market is balanced,
you can plot a profile on it. You'll
have your value area high, value area
low, the distribution of the profile.
Right? So, if we're to look at something
like this, this is a balanced market
until it went imbalanced, right? So,
buyers and sellers are interacting in
this area, right? With that, it remains
balanced until one side either
uh loses interest, the other side takes
initiative, and it breaks from balance,
right? Very straightforward. So,
something like that, you could put a
profile on it. So, from beginning of the
balance to the end of the balance,
right? Because all you're measuring is
the balance. You're not trying to
measure any of this.
Right? If this ever wants to load.
Right? So, you get a distribution.
Right?
Now,
where I see a lot of people going wrong
is, firstly,
they may measure from This is very
common from a starting point, whether
it's beginning of the week, beginning of
the month, beginning of the day,
whatever it happens to be, and they'll
either let that continue to current
price. So, let's just
for simplicity's sake,
we'll just say this is monthly open here
in the beginning of this profile.
They'll pull this all the way till
the end of the month, let's say.
Right? And issue with that is that
you're no longer measuring just balance.
You're measuring all of this imbalance.
You can see how skewed this distribution
is, right? So, in reality, if you were
to look at this properly, so, the
distribution of a profile is it To put
it simply, it's it's the shape or the
the characteristic of the traits of the
profile, what it looks like, right?
Something that is normally or evenly
distributed has more of a kind of
uppercase D shape, right? It's going to
look more like this. Okay?
A bell shape, whatever you want to call
it, right? Value area high will be up
here, value area low will be here. Point
of control's usually around here, right?
So, most of time and most of volume is
being spent here, right? And it tapers
off towards the edges, which is you
know, this is 68% of time or volume
spent, right? And this is one standard
deviation either side of that area,
right?
And that's what you'd call that you
know, that's a balance area. If the
market is not balanced, your profile's
going to look something like this in the
middle, where
you can't do anything with this, right?
So, go back goes back to the issue here.
If you're simply pulling a monthly
profile and using the value area on it,
it means largely nothing. Of course,
this is going to be some kind of a
support level, but you can't lean on
this level and say, "Oh, if we see
acceptance here, I know we're going to
trade up to here."
Or I anticipate that, because it's it's
largely wrong.
But in reality, you're only paying
attention to balance areas. So, it goes
back to my issue, like I said,
pulling profiles, you know, that's my
one issue it it is time-based profiles.
And I'll explain that, because obviously
I use daily, weekly TPO. Uh you can use
a daily volume profile if you want to.
There's nothing wrong with that, but the
issue is what the distribution looks
like. So, the issue with a weekly
profile or monthly profile, like I just
showed you, is it's going to measure
a day's sorry, a a month's worth of
data, regardless of what it looks like.
So, if there's no balance throughout
that entire month, it could be
completely useless to you.
When in reality,
let's pull this once more and we'll take
a look at it. You can identify where
balance actually persists, and that's
all you want. That's why me personally,
I like to get more granular and look at
especially something like a daily
profile, like daily TPO, and you see
where balance actually persists, and you
merge those days until it doesn't
anymore, right? So, you can do the exact
same thing with a volume profile just by
using your eyes, right? So, you can see
here the distribution of this. This high
volume node can be seen on price as this
balance area or this range. So, that
means you would pull the profile from
beginning to the end. That's it. Same
thing with this. You can see another
large high volume node here, which is
this range here.
That's basically all you want to be
working with from a medium-time frame
perspective is this area of balance and
this one. So, to say that oh, this is
value area low of the last 30 days,
that's great. It means absolutely
nothing to you aside from the fact maybe
it's it's a resistance level if we trade
into it.
But, it's also seen as value area low of
this range. So,
I go and show you what I mean.
We can go and pull a profile over this
and you'll see how much better the
distribution looks. See? The whole
profile is evenly distributed. The most
volume is here, tapers off, tapers off.
Of course, we had this larger dip, but
again, that doesn't really matter. You'd
still include all of this and then it
trades down. And you can even see
there's a retest lower time frame, could
have went short.
So, same thing can be seen here on this
other one.
All right, if we pull a profile over
this
from start to finish, if you want to put
it simply,
you can see we have an even distribution
more or less, right? Value area high is
up here, value area low is here, and
that's it. You don't measure all of
this.
So,
that's a huge issue I see with people.
So, for example, if you were to look at
This is Bitcoin, right? If you were to
look at last week's value, okay? This is
a great example of how useless this can
be if you do this wrong, which
in the trading space, 99% of people have
no idea what they're doing, including
influencers who who make tutorial videos
on whatever the popular
buzzword is or buzz term or popular
trading style. So, whether it's order
flow or profiles, I see all kinds of
people making videos on them now and
they have no idea what they're talking
about. Anyways, here's basically weekly
open, right? Also, the end of the month,
so let's pull it down, too. So, it's
last week. Last week's open to this
week's open, which would put you to
here.
Does this look like a balanced week to
you?
The answer is no. So, value area high
means basically nothing because there's
no
It's completely imbalanced. There's no
areas of balance here. This is the only
area here. This is what?
12 hours?
Maybe 16 hours, right? So, largely
speaking, this holds zero structural
importance on anything to do with
balance or applying AMT or anything like
that. The only other one would be here,
which is what a day, maybe? So, you have
a little high volume node here. So, if
you wanted to go to a lower time frame
and look at this, it's basically seen as
this. So, what you could do, if this was
relevant to how you trade, you could see
this is a high volume node here. So,
again, that would be your distribution.
Right? So, your value area high would be
somewhere around here. Value area low
was probably about here. So, just to
prove to you I'm not bullshitting, if we
go and pull that now, it's probably
about the same, right? Value area low,
value area high. I was pretty close,
right? I just eyeballed it.
So, that's what you'd get. But, to to
measure this entire area and say, "Oh,
that's the previous week value area
high,"
it's completely incorrect. If no balance
persists in the market, there's no
reason to ever put a profile on a
majority of the time.
If you were to try and see where the
point of control was or something like
that as as a minor inflection, you could
do that. But, to simply just use this
use this whole profile and say, "Oh,
here's value area high up here." It's
completely wrong.
So, if you have that in your head, it's
wrong.
The next one would be that we're kind of
building a balance here. But, again, you
could even be more granular and say that
this balance we have balance here,
right? We have this balance. So, they
don't even overlap yet. Of course, if we
spend more days down here, then, you
know, this distribution will grow and
there's probably a larger profile here
by the end of it, maybe four or five
days, right? But, again, you don't know
yet. So, really, if you were to look at
this properly,
you want to pull profiles over the
beginning of balance to the end of
balance, beginning of a range to the end
of the range. That's the most
simple way I can explain this to you.
So, doing something like this is
completely wrong. This is useless.
Okay? Cuz there's no balance. So, say
you were you, you know, you were to look
at this
and you wanted to measure this area on
on Bitcoin, right?
Um just disregarding even time frames or
periodicities. I'm not going to look at
daily profiles here. You could do that
if you wanted to. So, I I I
kind of cater more towards using TPO
than volume profile, though I use both
of them interchangeably all the time.
Uh if you were to look at this, the
easiest way to do this is say
you know, there's the beginning of this
range, right? It's ranging, we break
down from the range.
Pull it to where it ends.
Right? Even distribution, like I just
said, that's good.
Uh same thing here, range compression,
trades up, right? And then you get this
impulsive move. So, you could pull
something like this. That would be fine.
You can see we rejected value. You could
probably even go like this.
And that's still evenly distributed. So,
that would be fine.
It as long as value overlaps, again,
that's more of a TPO thing, but again,
the same concept applies if value
overlaps between two areas of balance or
two profiles, you can merge them.
So, same thing, if you want to take a
look here, you can see that price traded
into value, it traversed value, or maybe
retested value area low right here to
the tick, and now we're just rotational
here. So, if we spend multiple days
here, okay? You would merge this entire
thing ultimately because balance is
persisting.
So,
that's pretty much it. Uh next thing
I'll touch on here, just so we make sure
we're on the same page, is distribution
of the profile, the shape of the
profile, right? So, if the profile looks
like this,
okay?
If it's evenly distributed,
say it looks like that. That's good.
Value area low is here, value area high
is here. That's good. If the profile
looks like this,
is that evenly distributed? Is there
balance persisting throughout this day?
No, there's not. And I can verifyably
show you that one more time.
Cuz again, if we were to pull last
week's profile,
let's just begin, let's eyeball it from
here down to
there.
Is there any balance persisting around
here? Largely speaking, no. There's a
mini one there, a mini one there, but
no, this entire Look at the shape of it,
right?
The only bit of balance, like I said, is
seen here and here.
Right? If you were to look at something
properly,
like let's say we look at
this I think it was 9 weeks of of
balance here on Bitcoin. Right? This is
a very large area of balance. So, if you
were to measure this one,
if you pull a profile from beginning of
the range to the end of the range, which
you could argue is either here or here,
right? So, either this impulsive move or
this one, depending how you want to
break it down. That's basically what you
get. Like you can see here, this is a
good distribution, right? So, lower
volume. This is value. We trade up
there's the top of the bell curve of the
distribution and it tapers off.
Okay?
POC is a bit lower, but again, we have
another large high volume node here
right in the middle of the distribution.
So, if you were to take this profile and
pull this to current price,
see how entirely wrong that is?
This level means largely nothing.
Value area low is about the same, I
believe.
Right? So, it got that level properly
because there's nothing has has
developed down here to to counteract
that, but value area high, given we did
all of this, it's taking all of this
into consideration when these are
totally different balance areas all
together.
So,
if you were to look at this properly,
right? What you really have is a high
volume node here. You have another one
here, another one here. You have this
large one here, which is this range,
right? And then we've started to kind of
develop these ones down here. So, this
is balanced. This is balanced. This is
balanced. This is balanced. So on and so
forth. So,
uh hopefully I'm I'm sure there's
probably a lot of you found this really
helpful.
Um
really straightforward stuff when
someone explains it to you.
Um so, just make sure when you're using
a profile, one, the distribution looks
good, and two, you're not just using a
monthly or weekly profile for the sake
of saying it's a weekly profile because
it's entirely wrong. So,
uh should you guys want to learn how to
do all of this in extreme comprehensive
detail,
um join the Discord. Have a good one,
guys. Cheers.